a university offers a certain course
that students can take in person or in
an online setting teachers of the course
were curious if there was a difference
in the passing rate between the two
settings data from a recent semester
showed that 80 percent of students
passed the in-person setting and 75
percent of students passed the online
setting they were willing to treat these
as representative samples of all
students who may take each setting of
the course the teachers used those
results to make a 95% confidence
interval to estimate the difference
between the proportion of students who
passed the who pass in each setting of
the course so this is a 95 percent
confidence interval for the difference
between the proportion who passed the
in-person course and the online course
the resulting interval was approximately
went from negative 0.04 to 0.14 and just
to make sure we understand what this is
saying this is saying 95 percent of the
time that you go through this because
we're talking about a 95 percent
confidence interval 95 percent of the
time you take these samples and then you
construct a confidence interval for the
difference in proportions that it will
actually contain the true proportion
they want to use this interval to test
their null hypothesis that the true
proportions are the same versus their
alternative hypothesis that their true
proportions are different assume that
all conditions for infants have been met
based on the interval what do we know
about the corresponding p-value and
conclusion to their test so pause this
video and try to figure out on your own
all right so what's interesting here is
we're going to use a confidence interval
to think about a hypothesis test and
remember in a hypothesis test we assume
that our null hypothesis is true we'll
assume this and there's another way we
could write it we could write it like
this that the difference between the in
person and the online true proportions
is equal to zero these are equivalent
statements and a hypothesis test we will
assume that this is true and then at a
traditional hypothesis test we set some
significance level
so let's say we set that significance
level at 5% and that is a very typical
significance level and if the results we
get if the probability of the results of
getting the results that we do get for
the sample the difference in the sample
proportions is less than 5% we say hey
that's pretty unlikely we're gonna
reject the null hypothesis which will
suggest the alternative but here we have
something interesting we have a
confidence interval and it turns out
that if the some of your confidence
level and your significance level is
equal to 100% and you're doing a two
sided hypothesis test
so you're thinking about well our
alternative hypothesis isn't just that
the in person is greater than the online
or that it's less than the online it's
that they are different so we have a two
sided hypothesis test and these
situations you can actually make some
inferences about your p-value from your
confidence interval think about it this
way we are assuming our null hypothesis
is true when we do this hypothesis test
and so when we construct a 95%
confidence interval we would expect that
95% of confidence intervals of
confidence intervals would overlap
overlap with zero where did I get zero
from remember this is a confidence
interval for the difference in
proportions and our null hypothesis is
that the true difference in proportions
is zero so 95% of the time that we do
this if we assume that the null
hypothesis is true we will overlap with
zero or another way you can think about
it 5% of confidence intervals confidence
intervals would not overlap over lap
with zero and so if you are in a
situation where you go through this
process you try to construct a 95%
confidence interval and you don't
overlap with your assumed difference of
the true proportions from your null
hypothesis well in this situation your
pee
value is going to be less than your 5
percent significance level so in this
situation you would reject you would
reject your null hypothesis and in this
first situation you your p-value is
going to be greater than or equal to
your alpha level and you would fail to
reject fail to reject so what's the
situation here
well our interval actually does include
the assumed difference in true
proportions from the null hypothesis
so that means assuming the null
hypothesis we are in this first scenario
this is one of the 95% of confidence
intervals where we actually did overlap
with the true parameter that we are
trying to estimate and so in that
situation our p-value is going to be
greater than or equal to our alpha which
in this case is 5% and so we fail to
reject the null hypothesis and so there
isn't evidence to suggest that there is
a true difference in passing rates
between the in person and the online
exam